oh
fear is a powerful thing and it's
motivating many to leave a city called
her son
it's been occupied by the Russians for
the past seven months but the ukrainians
are edging closer and some here are
choosing to flee via ferries across the
Great danipro River these pictures were
taken secretly for the Russian
government still in charge yet there are
local residents who've Lost Their Fear
we expected to have to hide your
identity why are we able to to show your
face
Vlad is a writer organizer and activist
in her son
um
[Music]
Russia claims its evacuation is all
about protecting the civilians but our
interviewee says the Russians are
protecting themselves and their loved
ones local residents have to remain in
the city
[Music]
says the situation is difficult in the
city some think he's likely to withdraw
but they're still sending in troops
pictured here newly mobilized Russian
soldiers training in the region and our
interviewee says they're now taking up
posts in his City
foreign
occupiers Stand Accused of Acts of theft
large and small shops have been
ransacked businesses looted hear nothing
empty say these signs this one reads
everything's stolen our interviewee says
the cancer clinics been stripped
Russian officials have told civilians to
leave her son immediately it seems the
ukrainians are now close to the city the
next few days could be could be very
difficult
Liberation will not come easily John
Sparks Sky News in southern Ukraine